we're here at CES at digital experience
a press event for the show and this
thing on my head is called smart goggles
it's a virtual reality helmet right now
I'm playing a game in which I'm a robot
smashing a city I can jump up and smash
buildings it's an android-powered unit
there's actually a 1.2 gigahertz android
device in the helmet here and these
little circles in front aren't
decorative they're actually motion
sensors you can use your hands to
interact with the games as more games
become available this is code of a proof
of concept prototype but the company
actually hopes to bring this to market
by the end of the year for under a
thousand dollars and I got to say it's
it's pretty fun they're kind of heavy
they're a little hot I can't hear that
well but I'm smashing a building and I
mean that's really all that matters